today's episode of the program is
sponsored in part by Vikings if you
enjoyed the old school strategy and RPG
games of the 90s and 2000's which I
loved you will love Vikings the latest
update was so good that it placed the
game on the top 5 charts the game is not
only about clan battles nation versus
nation combats are also a big part of
the game and you have the opportunity to
choose your own play style this makes
Vikings unique if you know how to manage
people you can be a clan leader and
reign your Empire you're an economist by
heart you can use your skills to build a
prosperous city and an interesting fact
is that the Vikings game recently
reached 20 million players that's more
than 10 times the total population of
actual Vikings that ever lived
don't miss it let's help Vikings reign
again the david pakman show and Vikings
are giving away a new iPhone 10 and a
super prize a MacBook Pro you want to
get the iPhone 10 download Viking from
the links below and upgrade your palace
to level 5 you want to win the MacBook
Pro upgrade your palace to the highest
level you can until the end of the month
find out how to get your prize via the
Instagram link in the description the
giveaway is on February 28th don't miss
it we've spoken many times about
Filipino president Rodrigo Duterte the
guy with the death squads the guy who's
murdered many people the guy who wants
suspected drug dealers and suspected
drug users killed in the streets the guy
who wants women shot in the vagina as we
talked about last week I've also told
you that Donald Trump really likes the
guy in fact Trump's best relationships
kind of seemed to be with the
authoritarian dictator types we know
that Trump has no real political
philosophy but to the extent that he has
a personal philosophy that translates
the politics it's the sort of autocratic
authoritarians I don't know what other
words use that he matches up with right
the likes of Vladimir Putin Turkey Zaire
Diwan
North Korea's Kim Jong hoon and yes
Rodrigo Duterte as well and it's now
getting more awkward because the US
intelligence community has named Rodrigo
Duterte a threat to democracy in
Southeast Asia along with Hun Sen from
Cambodia and in some other some other
crises in the region are also being
looked at as threats to democracy this
is awkward
but it's another area where Trump is in
direct odds with the intelligence
community of the United States at direct
odds better said put aside for a second
Trump smearing of the FBI put aside for
a second the disbelief for really close
two years now about the conclusions of
the intelligence community as they
relate to Russia we're talking here
about world leaders right the Intel
community says duterte is a threat to
democracy and meanwhile Trump has
praised him for his great work on the
issue of drugs meaning his idea of
having dealers and users shot dead in
the street completely extra judicially
and the real risk here is that how the
United States officially views someone
like Duterte has geopolitical
implications in the region right if the
US president seems to approve of the
tactics that Duterte uses it gives
Duterte and those tactics apparent
legitimacy which is a disaster the US
intelligence community isn't doing that
but Trump is so another funny way in
which they're at odds but as is often
the case there's usually more to the
position of the US intelligence
community because in the last 48 hours
the Philippines has been activating
around the South China Sea and we've
covered before we interviewed luke
vargas about this actually rodrigo
duterte is seen as friendly to china
building military facilities on some of
the contested islands around the
philippines US intelligence clearly
doesn't like this it's not an unfair
criticism but we always have to consider
that there's always more than just do I
agree or disagree with Duterte being a
threat in the region a threat to
democracy there's always more to it now
Trump has no idea about that if you go
to
and you say what do you think about the
position of rodrigo duterte in the
context of the South China Sea
controversy I can assure you he has no
clue what's going on there but for us
it's important to understand that yes US
intelligence has other concerns when
they make these declarations well that's
why I think it makes America look weak
in a sense because if we're operating
from a bunch of different mouthpieces so
like the intelligence community is
saying one thing yeah president's saying
another thing these authoritarian
dictators will be able to essentially do
what they want because maybe they'll be
at odds with one of those entities but
the other will agree with them of course
they can manipulate that to their
advantage and it's actually kind of like
the foundation of why Russia would even
want to meddle in American elections
which is create chaos and create discord
internally which will then number one
give them more leeway to do whatever
they want and of course number two just
make them look better in the context of
the chaos of the United States yeah and
the intelligence community criticizing
Russia I don't think that's impacted
Putin in Trump's relationship now so I
don't think it would affect Trump and
Duterte relationship if the intelligence
community's going after him oh
absolutely not Trump just loves the guy
fascinating and stunning guy that's it
for today I am out of time no voicemail
but we've got a great bonus show for you
today sign up at david pakman.com slash
membership or get access to the bonus
show by making a $5 a month pledge at
patreon.com slash david pakman show